depuis presque quatre mois dans cette
commune la vie des habitants est rythmée
par des distributions de bouteilles
d'eau
[Musique]
trois bouteilles par jour et par
personne pour les 300 habitants de ce
village qui n'ont plus accès à l'eau
potable on s'habitue on s'habitue mais
bon il est temps que ça s'arrête quand
même puisque
c'est quand même une contrainte aussi de
venir deux fois par semaine chercher de
l'eau enfin mec en patiente ça va ça
reviendra potable c'est que ça commence
à devenir un peu long quoi cette
histoire alors je sais pas jusqu'à quand
ça va durer au mois de juin l'agence
régionale de santé informe l'Amérique un
pesticide interdit en France depuis 10
ans a été retrouvé dans les dernières
analyses d'eau un taux cette fois
supérieur au minimum autorisé elle est
alors interdite à la consommation ce qui
bouscule les habitudes des habitants il
faut faire les plaines des cafetières on
est obligé de l'utiliser pour
la cuisson des pâtes de la soupe
moi personnellement j'aurais les légumes
au robinet et la dernière eau j'utilise
un peu de l'eau en bouteille pour le
dernier rinçage une consommation de
plastique qui dérange ce couple de
retraité et pour qui les pouvoirs
publics devraient s'intéresser davantage
à la question de l'eau à l'âge que j'ai
je me fais plus vraiment beaucoup de
soucis pour moi-même mais je suis
inquiet pour mes petits-enfants parce
que la qualité de l'eau dégradée c'est
un vrai problème de santé publique donc
oui on a peut-être consommé de l'eau
polluée par le passé avant qu'on fasse
les nouvelles analyses bon on s'en est
quand même sorti aujourd'hui la source
de cette pollution n'est pas encore
identifiée mais il y a deux suspects
principaux les premiers les vergers de
pommiers sur les hauteurs du village
dont les pesticides pourraient se
retrouver dans les nappes phréatiques et
donc contaminer l'eau certains pointent
également du doigt les produits utilisés
pour nettoyer les hectares de panneaux
solaires situés à quelques mètres des
pommiers à la demande du procureur de la
République une enquête est en cours pour
éclaircir cette situation le maire de la
commune n'attend qu'une chose être fixée
4 pour savoir d'où la provenance de
cette pollution
savoir si c'est
l'origine industrielle agricole ou
accidentaire
occasionnelle
accidentelle occasionnels on a un peu 12
parce que les taux de pluie baisse pas
forcément voilà
on attend avec un patience
résultat de cinq pièces pour savoir d'où
provient ce problème et bon je pense que
ce sera encore assez long
malheureusement une solution provisoire
devrait être mise en place dans les
jours à venir une station de
potabilisation qui puisera son eau sur
le réseau d'irrigation plus tard le
castelet souhaite se raccorder à la
commune voisine d'oraison située à 6 km
mais les travaux sont coûteux entre 800
000 et 1 million d'euros
allons nous vivre une guerre de lots en
France comme l'existent déjà dans
plusieurs régions du monde voilà le
thème de notre débat et je vous présente
mes invités Marie petnati bonsoir bien
vu Bienvenue vous êtes hydrogéologue au
bureau de recherche géologique et
minière Frédéric dans et bonsoir
bienvenue journaliste écrivain
spécialiste des questions
environnementales je cite l'un de vos
livres rencontre avec des écolos
remarquables publiés aux éditions de la
chaux et Nestlé Nicolas Garnier bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi directeur
de l'association amorce qui réunit
collectivité territoriale et
professionnelle de l'énergie avec nous
en duplex j'accueille Gabriel boulot qui
est politiste à l'Institut national de
recherche pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et l'environnement
spécialiste des politiques de l'eau et
Mathieu croissanto est resté à mes côtés
évidemment avant de parler de cette
expression guère de l'eau j'aurais
rebondir sur le reportage que l'on vient
de de voir
cette enquête de nos confrères du monde
je reprends le chiffre là comment Marie
petmati peut-on passer en un an de 6% à
20% de Français qui ont reçu de l'eau
polluée alors ça s'explique très
clairement avec le fait que cette année
on a analysé la molécule incriminée dans
les eaux souterraines voilà si elle ne
fais pas partie de la liste de
surveillance préalablement c'est sa
découle des nouvelles directives sur la
surveillance de ces molécules voilà et
donc la RS cette année a imposé de
regarder spécifiquement cette cette
molécule qui a résidu de pesticides qui
est un métabolite de pesticides donc qui
vient d'un dégradation d'une première
molécule qui a pu être utilisée des
années et des années auparavant voilà
donc c'est pas une nouvelle pollution
c'est un degré dont on va dire
d'exigence un peu plus important oui
c'est à dire qu'on regarde voilà une un
nouveau panel enfin on élargit la liste
des molécules d'intérêt pour lesquels on
a des suspicions voilà de de d'action
néfastes sur l'environnement et sur la
santé d'une mère plus générale Frédéric
d'où vient cette pollution c'est quoi
c'est une sorte d'héritage on peut
est-ce qu'on peut dire ça comme ça
alors il y a une pollution immédiate
qu'on connaît qui arrive directement
dans l'eau c'est l'agriculture c'est
l'industrie c'est nous hein c'est nous
c'est souvent transmis par nos urines
qui 1% 65 % des molécules problématiques
pour les statuts d'épuration celles qui
exigent des la part des stations
d'épuration beaucoup de travail beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup d'argent se trouve
dans 1% du volume qu'elles ont à traiter
c'est nos urines on retrouve des
molécules pharmaceutiques des molécules
cosmétiques on retrouve tout ça et puis
effectivement c'est un héritage parce
que combien même on aurait fait en sorte
de ne plus polluer les eaux il en reste
de ces de ces pollutions qui sont
absorbées fixées légèrement sur le
sédiment fond des rivières et puis il y
en a qui sont qui se sont mises dans les
nappes phréatiques depuis des années les
nappes phréatiques et les sédiments des
rivières sont la mémoire économique et
industrielle du pays on retrouve
aujourd'hui dans les nappes phréatiques
des molécules qui ont été interdites il
y a 50 ans moi-même en fin d'études
quand j'analysais les sédiments du
bassin Picardie je retrouvais des métaux
lourds qui n'auraient jamais dû s'y
trouver et pourtant ils y étaient bien
planqués ils n'attendaient que le
passage d'une péniche pour repartir dans
l'eau donc c'est sans fin en fait et à
la fois l'eau il y a les sédiments et
encore en dessous il y a les nappes
phréatiques c'est pour ça qu'il faut
traiter tout effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit plus on cherche plus on
trouve et la liste de molécules à
étudier augmente et la liste des
métabolites de ces molécules augmentent
ce qui va à un moment de poser un
problème c'est à quel coup on va pouvoir
potabiliser l'eau notamment dans les
zones rurales où il y a moins d'armes
parce que moi par exemple j'ai arrêté
l'eau en bouteille etc je vais prendre
l'eau du robinet je vois cette nouvelle
je me dis bah qu'est-ce que je fais
est-ce que je fais j'imagine qu'il y a
pas mal de téléspectateurs qui sont dans
mon cas est-ce que je continue de de
prendre le doigt oui parce qu'elle est
de mieux en mieux contrôlée c'est ce que
elle est très contrôlée par rapport à
d'autres pays enfin c'est toujours la
différence entre le danger et le risque
le danger porté par ses molécules il est
très important en théorie le risque
qu'on a du mal à l'évaluer d'autant plus
que ces molécules elles sont toutes en
synergie failli ça sert pas à grand
chose de mesurer un taux d'une molécule
sachant qu'elle sachant qu'il y en a
plein dans l'eau et qu'elles vont
interagir ensemble dans notre camp donc
en fait on peut pas vraiment évaluer le
risque sur le long terme donc le danger
c'est oui mais tout sec en cérigène tout
ça aille mutagène reprotoxique il y a
plein de molécules qui peuvent nous
abîmer sur 30 ans mais on peut on ne
pourra jamais évaluer on pourrait jamais
faire un lien de causalité entre le
moment où vous buvez de l'eau et la
conséquence dans 30 ans par contre ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'on vous buvez de
l'eau du robinet nous met du robinet de
l'eau en bouteille là par contre le
risque porté par les micro-né il
nanoparticules de plastique celui-là il
est bien établi et on sait très bien où
finissait à nos particules vous les
buvez là vous l'aurez retrouvé dans les
testicules au bout de 8 jours voilà
c'est pour ça voilà le message le
message est passé Nicolas Garnier si on
essaye de régionaliser je sais pas si
c'est facile mais face à ce parlons des
pesticides est-ce qu'il y a des régions
plus touchées que d'autres moi je suis
un peu béotien je vais penser aux
régions viticoles est-ce que c'est vrai
est-ce que c'est plus compliqué que ça
oui il y a quand même une répartition
régionale mais d'abord il y a quelque
chose qu'on peut sur lequel on doit
insister c'est que il y a un autre
phénomène qui explique ces pics de
pollution c'est les problèmes
quantitatifs dont on va parler dans
cette dans cette émission c'est que
moins vous avez d'eau qui passe dans les
cours d'eau plus le polo est concentré
donc il y a un lien entre protection
quantitatif il faut qu'on consomme moins
d'eau pour qu'on ait plus d'eau pour qui
vous permettez diluer en tout cas que le
polo le polo soit moins présent et des
logiques où on va essayer d'éviter ces
polans et pour venir sur la question des
polans dans l'eau il faut savoir que
historiquement on a plutôt cherché des
métaux lourds et des pollutions
organiques parce que ça étouffe l'eau
pour faire simple et ce qu'on découvre
aujourd'hui c'est les métabolites de
pesticides les pollutions
médicamenteuses dont Frédéric a parlé à
l'instant tout ce qu'on absorbe un
moment donné se retrouve dans l'eau et
il y a plein de choses qui nous posent
problème et puis les microbilles de
plastique et là on revient à la question
de la pollution plastique était l'objet
de la dernière la dernière
émission que j'avais faite avec vous sur
la consigne des bouteilles plastiques
donc je vois que vous avez vous avez de
l'acier dans les idées quand vous voulez
des plastiques ou effectivement il y a
des nouveaux enjeux autour de la
pollution qui ne sont pas totalement
traités aujourd'hui par les politiques
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle à une loi
sur l'eau nous en disant il est temps
d'aborder sérieusement les métabolites
de pesticides les pollutions
médicamenteuses mais aussi la pollution
puisque le plastique est partout on y
reviendra évidemment dans dans ce débat
je voudrais ouvrir un chapitre sur avec
ce sous-titre la France était le béni
des dieux en matière de de quantité
d'eau sur son territoire je me tourne
vers vous Gabriel boulot peut-être pour
faire un premier constat est-ce qu'on a
perdu beaucoup de de ressources beaucoup
de points de captage pour ces questions
de qualité de l'eau dont on parle à
l'instant
alors si on s'en tient juste au captage
qu'on a perdu pour des questions de
qualité c'est environ 200 captages d'eau
potable qui ferment chaque année depuis
les années 90 selon les sources de la
Direction générale de la santé donc
effectivement c'est très important alors
c'est pour des questions de pollution
d'origine agricole mais aussi des
hydrocarbures et effectivement face à
ces pollutions qui sont difficiles à
traiter dont on vient de dire et
l'exemple que vous montriez en début
d'émission avec ce village qui était
inquiet de savoir quand est-ce que ça
pourrait devenir à nouveau potable le
problème c'est que ces héritages en fait
ils sont difficiles à traiter que la
plupart du temps les collectivités qui
distribuent l'eau à partir de ces
captages préfèrent fermer ses captages
et alors en fait les relations entre la
qualité et la quantité sont très liées
parce que la solution c'est
l'interconnexion avec d'autres
collectivités qui disposent de
ressources qui ne sont pas les mêmes
problèmes de de qualité mais du coup on
va dépendre des mêmes ressources et donc
il va falloir se partager davantage des
ressources quantitatives dont on a vu
cet été que elles étaient moins on
pourrait même ajouter que
en fait la recharge des nappes dans
lesquels on pompe pour ces usages
elle-même dépend aussi de d'enjeux qui
sont plus larges puisqu'en fait pour que
ces nappes se rechargent il faut que il
y ait des paysages dans lesquels des
zones d'expansion de crue soit possible
pour que quand les fleuves débordent ils
puisent puissent recharger les nappes et
que dans les villes on est aussi des
zones moins imperméabilisées pour que
l'eau s'infiltre plutôt que de
s'accumuler dans des zones où elle crée
des ruissellement qui sont des nuisances
donc le cycle de l'eau c'est quelque
chose d'assez large qui inclut
effectivement la façon dont on construit
la façon dont on envisage la circulation
de l'eau et effectivement les problèmes
de qualité et la quantités sont liées et
quand on perd des captages et bien en
fait on est amené à se partager
davantage des ressources qui sont plus
rares la France Bennie des dieux d'où
elle me vient je vais je vais vous
expliquer c'était il y a quelques jours
sur la chaîne économique Bismarck où je
travaille aussi je recevais un membre de
l'Académie des technologies un ancien
patron de d'une grosse entreprise de
gestion de l'eau on va pas la citer et
il me disait ça en matière de ressources
tôt la France est béni des dieux est-ce
que c'est toujours vrai alors je pense
que c'est difficile d'entendre ça après
ce qu'on a vécu c'était pour ça que
j'étais surpris
vous parliez de recharge d'aquifères de
Naples
c'est ça exactement les nappes
phréatiques cette année ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'on a eu quand même une
recharge hivernale qui s'est arrêtée
deux à trois mois plus tôt donc on part
avec un stock déficitaire il faut voir
ça comme un stock les eaux souterraines
mais un stock dynamique l'eau elle finit
par retourner au milieu d'ailleurs les
eaux souterraines elles soutiennent les
cours d'eau les débits des tirages en
été puis elles rejoindre gentiment la
mer alors non on va pas dire qu'on va
être béni des dieux puisque cette année
en plus on a cumulé sécheresse
météorologiques sécheresse des sols
sécheresse hydrologiques donc avec des
débits de rivière très bas voir
inexistants et puis des niveaux de nappe
bas à très bas sur toute une partie du
territoire donc c'est une épice pression
caduque j'étais peut-être vrai il y a
une dizaine d'années une expression
caduque tout à fait et si vous voulez ça
reste sur des croyances que la ressource
est en nous est une ressource
inépuisable qu'on peut disposer à merci
en quantité en qualité mais ça pose la
question voilà de se dire oui au jet de
l'eau mais je dois la traiter pour
qu'elle puisse être utilisable quel est
le coût du traitement de l'eau en
énergie en économie est-ce que cette eau
elle est disponible pour tous maintenant
il faut considérer la ressource en eau
comme une ressource de bien commun pour
tout le monde donc il faut pouvoir la
partager et pouvoir la préserver Mathieu
l'eau qu'est-ce que ça représente dans
le débat politique français qu'est-ce
qu'on peut en dire très mauvais
souvenirs
90 l'eau et la politique la distribution
de l'eau et la politique ça faisait des
une des journaux des articles des
articles parce qu'on parlait à l'époque
de corruption soit généralisée soit pour
avancer des concurrents soit pour
s'approprier telle ou telle commune bref
d'abord des très mauvais souvenirs et
puis ces revenus quand même dans le
champ du débat politique alors faut
rendre à César ce qui est ce qui
appartient à César pour le coup il faut
c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est
persuadé que l'eau ce que vous venez de
dire fait partie de ses biens communs
c'est une réflexion qui qui l'anime
depuis quelques temps c'est un sujet qui
met le tout à la fois l'aspect humain
l'aspect citoyenneté l'aspect
consommateur l'aspect entreprise mais
aussi de santé mais aussi de
géopolitique bref c'est un vrai sujet
politique au sens noble du terme il y a
consacré un livret de 25 pages dans
cette campagne présidentielle avec
beaucoup beaucoup de propositions qui
vont de l'établissement d'une règle
bleue sur le modèle de la règle verte
qui peut qu'on ne puisse pas plus de
ressources que la nature peut elle
reconstituées pour l'eau qui passe par
l'interdiction on l'a dit des plastiques
qui passent surtout par une gestion de
l'eau de différence c'est-à-dire que lui
veut que cette gestion soit commune
collective d'abord à l'échelle des
bassins versants ça serait confié aux
régions pour les pour les cours d'eau
mais aussi la municipalisation des de la
distribution de l'eau et puis à
l'échelle mondiale même qu'on est des
ambassadeurs de l'eau enfin qu'on est
espèce de système géopolitique qui se
préoccupe de cette ressource planétaire
alors d'autres sont mêlés Yannick Jadot
lui parce que les écolos c'était fait un
peu de distanciés sur cette question de
l'eau ils étaient plus sur l'air ils
étaient plus nucléaires mais alors
beaucoup d'écologistes qui vont entendre
qu'ils font crier parce qu'ils
travaillent sur l'autre depuis longtemps
et ce vraiment se débat sur l'eau il a
été mis sur la table il faut le
reconnaître par Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
aujourd'hui on voit émerger dans dans le
champ dans le champ politique les
questions de tarification sociale de
l'eau c'est la caisse comment à partir
de du moment c'est devient bien qui va
coûter de plus en plus cher car de plus
en plus rares est-ce qu'on fait les
premiers mètres cubes gratuits ou est-ce
qu'on différencie les tarifs de l'eau en
fonction que vous êtes simple
consommateur simple consommateur dans
votre résidence secondaire une
entreprise une administration bref
est-ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'on fait
différemment et puis et puis surtout un
système de taxe aussi Jean-Luc Mélenchon
proposer par exemple de taxer les eaux
minérales en disant ils sont
responsables épuisent beaucoup plus
qu'il ne devrait en plus il pollue avec
le plastique donc c'est eux de financier
la transition aquatique si j'ose dire
alors ça ouvre la question de la
politique de l'eau vous l'avez un petit
peu évoqué tout à l'heure Nicolas
Garnier la dernière grande loi en
l'occurrence moi sur l'eau ça date de
quand alors la vraie grande loi elle
date de 1992 donc c'est pas hier elle a
été révisée en 2006
mais hélas elle a 16 ans je vous donne
une petite anecdote mais j'ai été expert
à la Convention citoyenne on n'a jamais
parlé d'eau à la Convention citoyenne ou
presque c'est à dire que les questions
qu'on nous posait c'était l'énergie les
déchets la rénovation énergétique le
changement de voiture etc ça montre que
dans la population le sujet de l'eau
même si de temps en temps il y a un spot
qui est fait c'est pas encore un objet
sociétal vraiment ensuite parce que la
France belleise des dieux pendant des
pendant des décennies tout à l'heure
j'ai failli en disant quand on a 90% des
départements qui sont arrêtés sécheresse
vous êtes des diables je suis d'accord
aujourd'hui mais pendant on est nourrit
de cette impression que c'était une
ressource inépuisable et pas cher
mais donc d'une part on a on a une
société à supposer que les 150 était
représentatif on va pas faire des
balader dessus mais ça c'était pas un
sujet central de alors qu'ils avaient
open bar sur les questions d'une
certaine manière ensuite quand si on
prend la séquence de cet été on vit une
crise énergétique une crise climatique
inondation incendie et une crise
hydrique globalement c'est les deux
premiers sujets qui ont fait l'objet de
portage politique avec petite tête
exception d'un candidat à la
présidentielle je reconnais nous aussi
on a posé des questions présidents aux
candidats et très peu on parlait d'eau
quand on parlait aux candidats ils nous
parlait d'énergie ils nous parlait de
déchets nous parler de et donc on se
rend compte que finalement il manque
aujourd'hui probablement un projet
sociétal un projet politique c'est pour
ça qu'on dit normalement dans une
démocratie ça s'appelle une loi et à un
moment où finalement les représentants
du peuple viennent se poser la question
comment résoudre deux problèmes comment
on protège quantitativement les masses
d'eau comment les protège
qualitativement effectivement par
exemple c'est étonnant de voir que les
lois dont on a parlé de 92 et de 2006 ne
pose pas un objectif comme on en posa
dans le domaine du dérèglement
climatique vous avez une loi climat qui
dit on va réduire de 30% les gaz à effet
de serre vous avez une loi énergie qui
dit on va augmenter à 38% les énergies
renouvelables vous avez une loi d'échec
qui dit aussi que 65 et vous n'avez pas
une loi eau qui dit on réduit de alors
en fait il y a quatre trois ans il y a
eu des assises de l’eau mais c'est un
objet non législatif qui a dit ça serait
bien de réduire les consommations d'eau
de 25% d'ici 2035 tout le monde était
d'accord et depuis
c'est vraiment bien de réduire de la
campagne mais il y a pas de loi il est
pas passé c'est pas rien passé parce que
je peux vous montrer aussi plein de ce
que je voudrais dire quand même de
manière positive c'est quand on regarde
de près il y a plein d'initiatives
intéressantes vous avez des
collectivités qui ont développé le riz
ou je pense qu'on va en parler
c'est-à-dire le riz août d'idées de
réutiliser sans en parler le gâchez pas
mon chapitre j'ai prévu un petit
chapitre là-dessus il y a des
collectivités locales qui ont développé
la récupération d'eau de pluie par
exemple là demain se passe en projet de
loi de finance que vous êtes pas très
loin l'idée d'un crédit d'impôt sur les
récupération depuis que j'ai proposé par
plusieurs députés donc il y a plein de
choses intéressantes qui sont faites et
on cultive des pas des pommes de terre
avec des des eaux réutiliser également
il y a des économies d'eau qui se font
dans plein d'endroit on a parlé de de
lutte contre artificialisation mais
c'est pas généralisé c'est pas massifié
parce qu'il y a pas de projet collectif
et ça explique aussi le fait que tout à
l'heure on a parlé des plans je sais pas
si vous en parler plus tard mais par
exemple il y a des objets qui
s'appellent des stages c'est un peu
bâtard mais c'est des schémas directeur
d'aménagement et de gestion de l'eau et
ben il y en a pas partout en France il y
a que la moitié des territoires français
qui ont un schéma le directeur de
comment je vais protéger l'eau consommer
l'eau etc la moitié de la France m'en a
pas ça veut dire qu'elle a pas rien mais
de même vous avez par exemple des
arrêtés préfectoraux sécheresse mais
c'est du court terme ça veut dire demain
vous n'avez plus droit d'arroser
j'allais dire d'arroser vos voitures non
d'arroser vos plantes et de laver vos
voitures mais par contre qu'est-ce qui
se passe sur le long terme il y a pas
forcément de projet derrière donc on
sent qu'il manque un projet qui se
établit sur 10 15 20 ans et pour nous
c'est une loi parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on établira à la fois les objectifs
les conditions les moyens on parlera
peut-être finance mais l'eau n'est pas
cher c'est peut-être aussi un problème
on va en parler j'espère qu'on réussit à
reparler de de tout ça cette expression
guerre de l'eau en France je vais vous
demander ce que vous en pensez les uns
et les autres quelques chiffres qui ont
été trouvés par Quentin Calmet qui
préparait cette émission évidemment à
nos côtés qui consomme le plus d'eau en
France alors c'est l'irrigation des
cultures 45% donc on va dire
l'agriculture la production d'énergie
c'est 31% ensuite on trouve les ménages
à 21% et l'industrie à 4%
numérique dans les est-ce que vous dites
qu’on est face à une guerre de loups
est-ce que le terme est trop fort
aujourd'hui en terme est un peu fort qui
est des conflits c'est évident là j'en
ai un très très beau sur lequel je
pourrais m'étendre désormais on a pas le
temps sur la la comcom de Chartres oui
unité de commune de Chartres de Chartres
voilà où il y a un vrai conflit entre
les les gros agriculteurs qui prélèvent
systématiquement au-dessus de ce que la
préfète leur autorise après le prélever
y compris cet été et il y a un vrai
conflit avec simplement la régie
municipale qui gère le potable et les
m'a dit le président de cette régie
municipale les irigans s'en foutent ils
font ce qu'ils veulent alors est-ce
qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a guerre non
conflit oui mais on a des agences de
l'eau qui est quand même un modèle un
des rares modèles français qui s'est
exporté qui sont là pour gérer l'eau à
l'échelle des bassins versants à
l'échelle des fleuves et en dessous on a
les commissions locales de l'eau qui
gère à l'échelle d'un sous bassin
c'est-à-dire à l'échelle de rivière et
justement parce qu'il y a des
représentants de tous les usagers de
l'eau c'est ces structures
administratives permettent d'éviter les
conflits pour répartir l'eau et répartir
les budgets en termes d'investissement
ou si tu as les images tout à l'heure en
fait c'est les sages qui sont pas
l'échelle de la France bon enfin bref on
va pas rentrer dans le détail mais c'est
un système qui fonctionne bien mais qui
pourrait demain ne plus fonctionner
pourquoi parce que les agences de l'eau
ont des problèmes de financement parce
que elles sont obligées de financer
l'Office français de la biodiversité et
parce que par Le Mans et Sénat enfin via
Bercy leur impose de ne pas dépenser
plus qu'une certaine somme alors même
que elle pourrait le faire parce que
c'est elle qui récupère sur nos factures
des redevances c'est redevances sont
assises notamment sur la pollution de
nous et sur les quantités de consommer
or elles ne peuvent pas augmenter ses
redevances parce que sinon ça passe dans
le budget général de l'État et donc les
agences de l'eau qui financent tout ça
qui financent notamment ses adaptations
se retrouvent face à un mur elles n'ont
pas le droit de dépenser plus alors
qu'elles pourraient récupérer plus sur
sur nos factures et puis elles sont
elles ont un autre souci c'est
l'ingéniorité territoriale c'est-à-dire
à les conseiller les communes pour
savoir quoi faire
pas d'argent on embauche pas on licencie
et
voilà peut-être préciser jusque depuis
le début des années 2000 il y a quand
même une remunicipalisation de la
gestion de l'eau
privatismes on va dire c'est comme ça
gérer en direct besoin d'avoir des
financements qui viennent pour la
majorité des agences de l'eau on fait
rien sans les agences au passage on dit
privatisés en fait c'est pas privatiser
c'est-à-dire que le c'est un service
public local simplement soit vous pouvez
le faire en interne c'est des régies et
en fait ce qui se développe aujourd'hui
c'est un resserrage de boulons aussi des
délégations ça suivi qui a eu des
critères beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
stricts donc on a une reprise en main du
service public qui se traduisent soit
par des régies soit par des délégations
de service je voudrais revenir sur les
prélèvements parce que c'est un enjeu
majeur c'est que souvent on focalise sur
tel ou tel acteur l'avenir des
consommations d'eau etc en fait quand on
regarde aujourd'hui la France pour
fonctionner a besoin de 35 milliards de
mètres cubes d'eau qui alors pas tout à
fait parents
le vous savez quel est le premier
consommateur d'eau de ce pays
les centrales nucléaires assez nettement
près de 15 milliards de mètres cubes ce
sont les centrales nucléaires ensuite
vous avez des canaux qui alimentent le
canal de Provence etc ensuite à 5
milliards de mètres cubes vous avez nos
consommations ménagères ensuite à 3
autour de 3 vous avez le monde agricoles
et les industries ce qui fait que il y a
alors là vous êtes vraiment très je
décalage avec les chiffres
on a regardé les chiffres de manière
étonnante et ça monte surtout au delà
des chiffres c'est que c'est vraiment un
effort partagé c'est à dire que l'erreur
ça serait de filer la patate chaude au
monde agricole en faisant c'est de leur
faute dans les mondes agricoles ils ont
consomment beaucoup mais ils en
consomment surtout quand on en a pas
c'est ça qui fait qu'on les stigmatise
c'est qu'ils en consomme entre juin et
octobre mais par contre il y a une vraie
répartition à faire entre le monde de
NRJ ça pose d'ailleurs la question de
l'avenir du nucléaire et de son
doublement du parc comment vous allez
refroidir le parc si vous n'avez plus
d'eau et puis ensuite la question de
savoir comment les ménages peuvent
consommer moins comment les services
publics François et moi les industries
et c'est là on dit il s'agit de répartir
un effort c'est comme dans les gaz à
effet de serre ou il faut répartir
l'effort de de sobriété pour est-ce que
Gabriel boulot je voulais pas redonner
la parole depuis un bon moment cette
expression garde de l'eau est-ce que
vous l'utilisez vous pour caractériser
la situation en France en ce moment
c'est vrai que cet été on a vu des
militants écolo peut-être les plus
radicaux que ça prend à des golfs
c'était encore vrai il y a quelques
jours à Saint-Cloud où aller ou au
bassine agricole à des retenus d'eau etc
etc est-ce que vous employez cette
expression vous
moi c'est une expression qui a été
utilisée en géopolitique et plutôt des
guerres entre État et d'ailleurs c'est
très
c'est assez contesté dans le monde
académique parce que en général l'eau
est tellement importante puisque on
s'arrange avec des traités il y a
beaucoup plus de traités de paix qui
traitent de l'eau que de guerre qui sont
liées à cette eau alors il y a des
épisodes de conflits importants mais il
faut dire que
on est dans un état de droit et que il y
a quand même beaucoup de ces conflits
qui nécessitent un arbitrage et la
question c'est peut-être d'arbitrer de
façon plus transparente peut-être à des
temporalités un peu différentes c'est à
dire qu'on a besoin à la fois ta
arbitrage à long terme donc il a été dit
qu'effectivement on a parlé des agences
de l'eau et des étages c'est à dire des
schémas directeurs qui sont justement
dans les grands bassins des documents
qui permettent de dire sur les 5 ans qui
viennent comment est-ce qu'on va
partager l'eau ou seront les priorités
et comment est-ce qu'on va les financer
à travers les redevances que
les agences mais il y a aussi des
arbitrages qui se font à court terme au
moment des crises notamment des
sécheresses où on a des comités
sécheresses qui sont dirigés par les
préfets pour arbitrer sur les usages qui
seront les plus vulnérables qui sont
prioritaires l'eau potable en général
dans ces comités sécheresses et reconnus
comme prioritaire et du coup des
objectifs de réduction et quand
j'entends que à certains endroits des
régimes municipaux n'arrivent pas à
faire respecter ce que le préfet a
imposer à certains usages on est
effectivement dans le problème des
dérogations qui sont effectivement
souvent peu transparentes dans les
arrêtés qui sont prises sur ces dans ces
situations de crise et puis
au-delà de la gestion à très court terme
il y a la question de la sanction en
temps réel et là il faut dire que ce
troisième volet de contrôle des
pratiques il est assez déficient et
effectivement avant de parler de guerre
de Londres on pourrait dire comment
faire en sorte pour que les décisions
qui ont été prises soit respectées et
qu'on est un État de droit sur ces
questions de prélèvement et de
pollutionnons les fraudeurs on peut dire
ça comme ça les tensions on les a vu se
multiplier je l'évoquais rapidement
autour de ces retenues ces bassines
agricoles je vous propose d'entendre un
exploitant il fait de la polyculture il
en défend le principe l'hiver on a trop
d'eau l'été on en a plus assez sur
l'année la quantité d'eau sont toujours
les mêmes sauf qu'on est des plus grands
des plus en plus d'amplitude c'est à
dire on a trois mois de pluie et ensuite
trois mois de sec et aujourd'hui si on
stoppe pas l'eau pendant qu'on a des
périodes très humides qu'on pourrait
utiliser pour les périodes sèches on
s'en sortira pas donc alors il s'appelle
Robin Lachaud
Nicolas Garnier désolé
qu'est-ce qu'on peut est-ce que vous
comprenez ces agriculteurs on peut
commencer par là je les comprends
évidemment c'est une d'une importance
capitale d'avoir cette ressource pour
assurer sa sub
évidemment c'est difficile de dire
demain à tous les agriculteurs on va
vous retirer les retenues les non ce
qu'il faut faire c'est avoir une vision
moins court thermiste parce que c'est
une vision courtesse court thermiste la
question des bassines et ça pose la
question du partage de l'eau ça pose la
question aussi de de la déconnexion de
cette masse d'eau du cycle de l'eau
c'est à dire qu'on va soumettre une sur
superficie d'eau à l'évaporation donc on
va perdre de l'eau donc on parlait des
prélèvements d'eau dans les différents
compartiments oui certes je suis pas pro
nucléaire mais
certes il consomme beaucoup d'eau mais
c'est vrai que l'agriculture elle
prélève de l'eau elle la restitue pas au
milieu sous forme moteur
le monde n'est pas rose mais
centrales nucléaires qui font que en cet
hiver ça serait une bonne nouvelle mais
c'est vrai que le l'agriculture va pas
restituer l'eau au milieu de sous forme
liquide ça va s'évaporer ça va être
repris par la plante et en fait là où la
plante on a le plus besoin ça va être
une période où même si on a des pluies
l'eau va être évaporée par tourner
recharger les nappes donc lorsque on met
en place ces retenues donc c'est des ça
peut être très grand super bassine
parfois
gigantesque voilà et Ben se pose la
question de où est-ce qu'on prélève
l'eau donc il y a beaucoup de bastines
qui prélèvent dans les eaux souterraines
donc nous on fait des études sur quel
est l'impact de ces de ces bassines sur
l'écosystème sur le milieu sur la valve
en fait du bassin qui qu'est ce que ça
va faire est-ce que ça va retirer de
l'eau aux autres etc et donc c'est des
choses qui s'utilisent vraiment au cas
par cas demain la transition elle va pas
être radicale c'est pas parce que cette
année voilà on a eu une crise qui a eu
des précédents je tiens à le dire depuis
cinq ans on manque déjà d'eau mais ça
peut être un annonciateur des des étés à
venir exactement surtout si je reviens
sur ce déficit de recharge que on a subi
cette année et donc il va falloir qu'il
pleuve beaucoup beaucoup cet hiver voire
même excédentairement pour réussir à
récupérer le stock donc on apprend à ne
pas se plaindre le matin quand il quand
il pleut en se disant c'est bon pour les
nappes phréatiques donc c'est vrai c'est
aussi une question d'état d'esprit face
face à la météo tout à fait et ce qui
est important de garder en tête c'est la
multitude des solutions alors je sais
pas quand on va parler si je peux en
parler maintenant
est retenu ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'il y a eu le après les acides de
l'eau il y a le ministère de
l'agriculture et le ministère de la
transition écologique qui ont collaboré
pour réfléchir autour des solutions pour
permettre de mobiliser des ressources en
eau voilà et de réfléchir à cette
transition agroécologique qui est
nécessaire voilà pour pouvoir partager
cette ressource et en consommer beaucoup
moins parce que le mot d'ordre c'est la
sobriété la première solution c'est
d'essayer de consommer le moins d'eau
possible les grandes villes ont réussi à
peu près à le faire alors que la
croissance démographique est bien là et
là c'est de d'avoir un véritable travail
sur les filières agricoles pour pouvoir
adapter ses cultures à ce changement de
climat qui qui nous occupe et il y a
aussi la révision du matériel
d'irrigation d'aller vers des techniques
beaucoup plus performantes et donc
pardon parce que j'en viens aux eaux
grises
cette irrigation dont on parle elle est
faite à l'eau potable
ultra majoritairement oui non elle est
faite à partir d'où souterraine elle est
faite à partir d'autres surfaces les
eaux qui sont prélevés dans les cours
d'eau sont pas forcément potabilisés
elles sont pas potabilisées pour
l'irrigation mais elles prennent dans
une ressource qui va être
potentiellement potabiliser plus tard
pour l'eau potable exactement
on passe les bornes incendies certaines
sont faites avec des eaux potables
certains lavages de véhicules donc c'est
pour ça qu'on dit qu'il y a plein
d'usages il y a 5 % de la consommation
d'eau potable qui est de pour des
besoins de potabilité le reste y compris
nos toilettes on n'a pas besoin d'eau
potable pour nos toilettes donc c'est
étonnant de se dire qu'on se donne à mal
de chiens pour faire de l'eau potable en
fait il y a une grande partie qu'on
pourrait consommer avec d'autres
produits
sur la réutilisation de usée traité oui
c'est une solution pour différents
usages c'est ne pas que pour
l'irrigation ça peut être pour nettoyage
des voiries pour des usagers industriels
l'industrie en circuit fermé le fait
déjà pas mal là il faut accélérer c'est
sûr aujourd'hui ça représente 8
milliards de mètres cubes à peu près qui
sont rejetés au milieu en France de nos
eaux qui viennent de l'eau potable qui
passe par les stations d'épuration qu'on
rejette au milieu on en réutilise
seulement 1% c'est entre 8 et 10
millions de mètres cubes par an c'est
rien du tout donc là il s'agirait de
d'avoir une un développement de cette
réutilisation pour pour tous les
réaction sur ce thème là c'est la
réaction d'un directeur du territoire de
l'eau de chez Veolia il s'appelle
Frédéric Sala Veolia qui a mis en place
dans six stations d'épuration française
une nouvelle technologie justement pour
traiter
l'eau provenant des égouts et la rendre
suffisamment propre pour l'irrigation
agricole le nettoyage urbain l'arrosage
des espaces verts des stades ou des golf
on écoute Frédéric salin France en fait
on utilise moins de 1% de d'eau usées
traitées en fait alors que si on regarde
les pays à côté de chez nous donc
notamment l'Espagne ils sont à peu près
à 15% l'Italie a 8 % parce que voilà
aujourd'hui il y a vraiment une
nécessité vue les épisodes de ces sèche
qui s'accumulent au fil des années de ce
projeter dans un futur qui pourrait être
proche de ces pays que ça soit l'Italie
ou l'Espagne il y a une vraie nécessité
justement de d'anticiper ces difficultés
futures et de de déployer ce type de
solution
Frédéric dans les règles en matière
d'utilisation de ces eaux usées ou ces
eaux grises et est-ce qu'il faut les
est-ce qu'elles sont trop strictes en
fait c'est une des questions elles sont
sans doute trop strictes vous savez
avant la bande maraîchère qu'il y avait
autour de Paris jusque dans les années
50-60 était ensemencé fertilisé par les
déchets des toilettes des Parisiens les
terres de champagne qui n'étaient juste
propre qu'à accueillir des moutons sont
devenus agricoles parce que certes on
les a demandé mais aussi on leur a
destiné beaucoup de bout de station et
d'eau usées qui venaient des toilettes
des Parisiens sachez ça qu'on vous
buurez du quand vous buvez du champagne
ce soir Thomas donc oui alors ça a été
interdit parce que des gens sont tombés
malades certains sont morts parce que
ben voilà le produit de nos toilettes
quand on le déverse comme ça à peine
épuré il y a toujours des gerbes
microbiens il y a toujours des virus
mais entre le à peine épuré et les
règles il y a peut-être effectivement on
peut arroser la voirie on peut on peut
faire pipi dans autre chose et avec
autre chose que de l'eau potable après
se pose une question économique tout ça
c'est c'est un autre modèle économique
ça veut dire d'autres réseaux ça veut
dire nouvelle canalisations et puis
c'est de l'eau qui infinie c'est pour ça
qu'il faut bien mesurer qu'il faut avoir
une stratégie globale qui ne retournera
pas tout de suite dans les milieux
naturels donc le pilotage doit être très
fin entre ce dont on a besoin pour un
usage ce qui doit retourner au milieu
naturel ce qui doit retourner dans les
Naples et on peut se poser aussi la même
question pour les canaux par exemple
est-ce que le canalsen Nord on doit la
remplir demain ce serait une gigantesque
bassine en fonction de la ressource
qu'il y aura demain
que demain on pourra arroser des
cultures ou arroser des voiries avec
juste le produit d'une eau qui a déjà
été utilisé tout ça ça se pense à
l'échelle d'un territoire sur des
temporalités différentes et pour
l'instant ne le fait pas c'est chacun
dans son silo chacun son usage on dit
intervenir oui ça peut retourner au
milieu en fait il y a des pays qui
développent beaucoup ça c'est à dire un
traitement adéquat pour stocker l'eau en
aquifère et là on nappe nappe phréatique
il a réutilisé après en Californie c'est
80 voilà le rachargement des nappes
c'est plus de 85% des eaux de de des
alentours de Los Angeles qui sont
réinfiltrer dans les nappes pour être
réutilisées elles servent également à
être injecté en milieu littoral afin de
combattre l'intrusion saline pour
assurer une distribution en eau douce
derrière en fait voilà est-ce que
Gabriel boulot on peut effectivement
comment je peux dire ça et aider la
nature c'est à faire en sorte que les
nappes phréatiques se ressourcent et se
remplissent plus rapidement
probablement je suis politique je vais
pas vous répondre sur les solutions
techniques c'est vrai que ces solutions
techniques elles apparaissent comme
souvent ce qui va permettre de résoudre
la question et donc on essaye à plein
d'endroits d'essayer de mieux utiliser
ce qu'on a donc on a parlé de la
réutilisation à certains endroits de
retenir l'eau pour les usages mais comme
tout ça est dans un cycle en fait l'eau
qu'on retient dans les retenues c'est
pas que elle était perdue sinon c'est
qu'elle allait à Laval et elle sera plus
disponible pour Laval donc en fait
souvent le fait de pouvoir avoir une
solution ça a tendance à pas changer le
modèle de consommation alors qu'en fait
on a vraiment besoin de changement
important
on l'a dit sur l'agroécologie et
effectivement dans l'ensemble des usages
il faut veiller à atteindre une
meilleure sobriété et le problème de ces
solutions techniques qu'on ait de nature
ou qu'on l'aide pas en fait le problème
de disposer d'une ressource qui a l'air
plus abondante et bien c'est que ça a
souvent un effet rebond c'est-à-dire que
l'eau dont on a l'impression qu'on peut
disposer en plus grande quantité nous
incite à l'utiliser pour autre chose on
le voit quand on améliore par exemple
les techniques d'irrigation on passe au
goutte-à-goutte en économise de l'eau
mais en fait l'eau économisée elle est
souvent réutilisée pour pouvoir faire
d'autres surfaces irriguées finalement
ça a tendance à verrouiller le modèle
qui n'est pas très résilient il y aurait
plutôt à repenser ce modèle d'autant
plus que on parle d'un stock mais en
fait il y a quand même beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur une année à l'autre
de quel stock on va pouvoir disposer et
il y a pas de garantie du tout et donc
moi je pense à tous ces agriculteurs qui
investissent dans des retenues et je me
dis il y a des années où elles vont pas
se remplir où on pourra pas les remplir
parce que il y a des sécheresses qui
sont on a dit dépendantes de déficit qui
arrive l'hiver et si l'hiver suivant ça
se remplit pas les nappes elles pourront
pas pas être pompé pour remplir ses
retenues donc on peut avoir des
phénomènes de pluriannuels ça s'est vu
cet été en Californie ça fait plusieurs
années que le lac Powell diminue de
niveau et en fait les nappes elles
diminuent de plus en plus en fait on
pourrait avoir des phénomènes voilà qui
font que les solutions techniques ne
sont pas suffisantes en fait il faut
aussi penser des solutions
réglementaires ou on réoriente les aides
publiques en faveur d'une agriculture
plus sobre en eau d'une d'usage
urbain aussi plus sobre et puis des
interdictions voire des des outils
fiscaux aussi alors justement il nous
reste allé un peu moins de 5 minutes
dans ce débat on va terminer sur la
question du prix de l'eau alors
évidemment en cette période d'inflation
de mesure pour soutenir le projet le
pouvoir d'achat des Français bon
peut-être un peu un peu anti-climax je
pourrais dire ça comme ça mais à vous
entendre les uns les autres le il faut
augmenter le prix de l'eau c'est comme
changer les usages je sais pas si vous
avez les heures de grandeur en tête mais
en gros une famille française c'est à
peu près 400 euros
enfin 500 euros c'est 3500 euros
d'énergie ça explique d'ailleurs
probablement l'acuité qu'on a sur
l'énergie parce que là on vient de voir
et puis c'était 3500 avant la crise donc
je vais peut-être vous dire 7000 la
semaine prochaine mais donc on sait pas
très cher c'est vrai et ça explique
aussi le fait que dans la tarification
aujourd'hui vous rendez compte vous
parliez des golfs mais le dernier mètre
cube pour arroser son golf coûte le même
prix que le 1er mètre cube pour boire et
on a aujourd'hui il y a quand même des
collectivités particuliers Dunkerque à
développer des logiques de tarification
incitatives et sociales les deux
incitatif parce qu'il faut consommer
moins social parce qu'il faut donner les
premiers mètres cubes pas cher mais
c'est les deux faut faire ensemble à
trop entendu social donc les premiers
mètres cubes pas cher et il faut
absolument créer cette dégressivité du
prix de l'eau ça c'est le premier
élément puis deuxième élément tout ce
qu'on a dit aujourd'hui on n'a pas parlé
des réseaux mais on a aussi des réseaux
fuyards donc il faut absolument il faut
absolument un milliard un milliard de
mètres cubes d'eau perdus chaque année
donc entre eux faut qu'on consomme
différemment il faut faire de la
sensibilisation faut attaquer le
problème de la prévention à la source en
allant voir le monde agricole le monde
des médicaments etc se dire qu'il faut
développer le Ryuk qui n'est pas donné
toujours d'ailleurs le Ryota n'est pas
toujours rentable donc la récupération
des eaux des autres des zones non
conventionnelles traité finalement
traiter aussi en sortie station
d'épuration ces nouveaux polans parce
que on va pas tout régler en disant que
ces choses ne vont plus jamais arriver
dans le cycle de l'eau tout ça ça coûte
cher effectivement il est probablement
temps de repenser un peu à l'économie du
de j'allais dire du mètre cube à la fois
dans sa dégressivité mais aussi dans la
capacité à intégrer de nouveaux coups
par exemple oui peut-être que on paiera
un peu plus cher ces médicaments ou ses
emballages plastiques ou ses vêtements
je vous rappelle que 75% de nos
vêtements sont en plastique et qu'à
chaque fois que vous faites une machine
vous larguez des microbiers de plastique
c'est comme ça il est probablement temps
effectivement qu'on assume le coup de la
protection de nos masses d'eau et de la
fraternité et vous êtes souvent là pour
ça parce que vous aimez bien c'est le
titre de votre livre elle est rencontre
avec des écolos remarquables une
initiative autour de l'eau qui vous
semble je sais pas intéressantes
exemplaire une bonne pratique à partager
ah bah c'est une initiative moi qui qui
me fascine j'en ai déjà parlé ici je
crois c'est celle de Mont-de-Marsan
Alain quartier qui était celui de la de
la caserne de pompiers qui est alimenté
en en eau chaude par la géothermie et
jusqu'à présent en hiver donc il y a
l'eau qui rentre au sommet des
radiateurs et puis l'autre qui ressort
en bas du radiateur et cette eau était
balancé dans la rivière 45 degrés les
poissons remontés cuits et des
agriculteurs ont dit ben non on va la
récupérer c'est tout pour le coup on va
la mettre à rafraîchir dans une bassine
et on ne l'utilisera plus que l'été
moyennant quoi on ne pompera plus dans
la rivière pour l'irrigation c'est tout
bête il a fallu simplement que la
personne qui s'occupe de l'eau à la
ville et la personne qui s'occupe de
l'eau la Chambre d'Agriculture se rend
compte accepte de se dire que l'autre
n'a pas forcément tort ils ont trouvé un
terrain d'entente c'était financer un
parti par l'Agence de l'Eau la Région
Département c'est tout bête sinon
c'était une eau qui était perdu dans la
rivière et qui faisait que cuire des
poissons avec vous imaginez les
conséquences chez les écolos qui étaient
pas contents et là manifestement tout le
monde est content et ben pourquoi on
fait pas ça partout parce qu'il faut que
les gens se rencontrent et on a un pays
maniché un ou forcément enne
Mont-de-Marsan allez retenez ça si vous
êtes élu que vous travaillez dans une
mairie parler de l'expérience de l'eau à
Mont-de-Marsan autour de vous merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
rappelle encore une fois le titre de
votre livre rencontre avec des écolos
remarque câble édition de la chaux et
nièceley à demain 18h 22h c'est le
rendez-vous sur Public Sénat et puis
avant cela ne ratez pas c'est à 8h du
matin dans bonjour chez vous orioni
reçoit Bruno retaillod le président du
groupe l.aero Sena candidat vous le
savez à la présidence du parti belle
soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]